Everything we invested
our energy into
and our hearts into,
it turned into something
that changed the world.
I can't say
that I immediately
jumped into the process
with an outline in mind.
How will I write
so that people believe me?
And how will I write it
so that they understand me?
I think that's
a natural thing to feel
when you sit down
to write any book,
but especially a memoir.
I wanted to feel
recognized as a person.
But I also wanted to be
understood as a writer.
I wanted people
to understand
why the people around me
believed what they believed
and why they behaved
the way they behaved,
and why I couldn't
even hold it against them.
What you learn in the
first third of Unorthodox
is an internal
process of questioning
and doubting
that occurs in the mind
of the protagonist.
At the end of the day,
the story was
about a woman's body.
And so when I first
started writing,
that was
the part I wrote about,
and it was originally
from my blog.
It was… That was, for me,
the center of my story.
I went back into the past
and I plucked
episodes from my life
and I
sorted them
chronologically,
next to each other
in order to build
some kind of arc.
I remember talking
to a Japanese reporter
when the Japanese edition
of Unorthodox
was released as a book,
and she was telling me,
"Do you know that the story
of every Japanese woman's
life is Unorthodox?"
She started to cry.
It's almost like,
instead of this just being
my weird,
unusual life experience,
it's now part
of a universal spectrum
of the experiences of women.
Wherever I go and talk
to people in the industry,
they're, like,
"You should never think
of your readers
when you're writing.
You shouldn't write
for your readers,
you should always write
for you."
And I broke that rule.
I broke so many rules.
My book should never
have been successful
considering
how many rules I broke,
but I thought about
my readers all the time.
They were the ones
I wanted to reach.
There is no reason
for a woman
to experience shame
as a result
of this very common,
lived body experience.
And that, to me,
is what I think
touched a nerve for women
all over the world.
I feel
as if I have been
emancipated
from my own story.
I think that's
the power of storytelling.